whatever happened to reading let's look
at some of my recent book
recommendations as many of you know
david pakman.com slash recommendations
an extensive list extensive list of
fiction and nonfiction books people
often email me david you have any book
suggestions yes I do
david pakman.com slash recommendations
let me give you four more to nonfiction
and to fiction books i recently read
this book into the wild by Jon Krakauer
the book is from the late 90s it is
about a young man named Chris McCandless
who after giving away twenty four
thousand bucks that he had saved to an
environmental group basically went into
the wild in rural Alaska and did not
make it out alive and what Jon Krakauer
does who is a sort of an out-and-out
doors climbing this sort of journalist
about out outdoor activities and sports
and a climber himself he followed Chris
McCandless trip and pieced back together
what happened the book is excellent it
is sad and it is a it is a great
combination of sort of narrative
nonfiction with investigative work and
science it's a very quick read only what
is it about 180 pages or so read it in a
few days really great book into the wild
by Jon Krakauer second nonfiction
recommendation this I've never read
anything before by Edward o Wilson but
now I have and I read the book the
meaning of human existence Edward o
Wilson is a biologist and naturalist and
the book is an overview of such topics
as what makes humans different from
other species what is the significance
of Homo sapiens not only on the planet
but in the solar system and even
questions more broadly about our role in
the universe there's some environmental
stuff there's some animal behavior stuff
fascinating stuff about everything from
ants to culture could not recommend this
more highly also a very quick read only
a couple hundred pages and it is very
very readable to use a term that I sort
of don't like but I think does
communicate kind of what I what I mean
here it is
densely packed with citations and
footnotes in that type of thing it's
it's very well put together in terms of
communicating a lot of information in an
accessible way the meaning of human
existence by Edward o Wilson to
nonfiction recommendations let me give
you two fiction recommendations now this
book was recommended to me by Joe
Rogan's guest Booker who I think knew
that I like the genre sci-fi genre the
book is doomsday book by Connie Willis
Connie Willis I've previously
recommended her more recent work
blackout and all clear this book is from
I believe the early 90s maybe written in
1992 and it is a sort of time-travel
caper which does have a sort of a plot
point that relates around a contagious
virus it felt a little all too real
reading some elements of this right now
but Connie Willis is one of the best
when it comes to time-travel sci-fi and
I think you would really enjoy this book
doomsday book by Connie Willis and
lastly the Testaments this is the sequel
to The Handmaid's Tale by Margaret
Atwood it is it fills in a lot of the
unknowns if you recently read or read
some time ago Handmaid's Tale this is
the sequel but it also tells us a lot
about sort of how the universe that
exists in Handmaid's Tale came to be
Margaret Atwood is absolutely one of the
best and I could not recommend this more
highly as well if you've already
forgotten about all of these
recommendations don't worry they are all
cataloged at david pakman.com slash
recommendations and by the way if you
use any of the links at david pakman.com
slash recommendations to get these books
we get a little slice remember when
andrew yang used to say that we get a
slice of an amazon transaction we the
david pakman show get a slice of your
amazon transaction if you pick up these
books or anything else on Amazon
wink-wink by using the recommendation
links at david pakman.com slash
- recommendations we have an excellent
program for you today there is so much
to discuss including the follow-on
repercussions of Super Tuesday as well
as we've got more primaries right around
the corner just a few days away and then
more primaries seven days later by then
I believe that this primary may be
effectively over we will talk about all
of that and more an Tuesday Biden Bernie
everybody's here the whole gang thanks
for joining me on this Friday program we
will take a quick break and get right
back to it after this